hello everybody markiplier here I wanted
to give you guys an idea of the next
goal that I had for this channel because
if you've been with me for a while you
know that I I had an original goal of a
hundred thousand subscribers in a year
and we blew that goal out of the water
we hit it about four weeks ago and my
gold date was in June
so that's months from now and you guys
did an incredible job to help this
channel grow doing everything and I
wanted this I wanted to share some
statistics I used to do this a lot but I
haven't done in a while so it's actually
kind of impressive if you compare it to
the other v-log that I've had and the
statistics that I've shown um we're
currently at 138 thousand eight hundred
twelve subscribers as of me recording
this video and probably more by then
because we're growing pretty crazily in
in the past month alone these are only
for the past 30 days there has been
roughly a hundred and twenty years of
content watched a hundred and twenty
years which is somewhere in the range of
five hundred fifty five million seven
hundred ninety thousand one hundred
ninety seven minutes that's just in the
past 30 days um and we've gained 47
thousand subscribers forty-seven
thousand one hundred fifty-nine
subscribers since 30 days ago so we hit
a hundred thousand subscribers less than
a month ago and I've kind of been
holding off on making a new goal because
I wasn't sure where we were going or
what I wanted I kind of hid it and was
like in a limbo for a while like oh man
what do I actually want to do with this
channel anyway well I'll get to that in
a second we've had two hundred and
thirty thousand nine hundred and forty
nine likes with only two thousand six
hundred and thirty nine dislikes that's
a ninety-nine to ninety-nine percent to
one percent ratio roughly so that's
pretty darn good
ninety nine percent of all the content
on my channel has been voted up to that
level and we've got twenty five thousand
eight hundred and twenty-five favorites
I can't talk and eighty nine thousand
nine hundred and eighty nine comments
which roughly translates to about seven
1 million seven hundred ninety nine
thousand seven hundred
words averaging about 20 words per
common there were some pretty beefy
comments in there but uh I'm just giving
a lowball average and there's only been
one thousand nine hundred and fifty-two
shares now that may seem like a small
number but sharing has always been
something that isn't as actively done
because it's not as easy but I've
thought more I thought a lot about where
I want to take this channel and what I
want to do with it and where I want to
go with you know the content that we
produce here and what we do with this
everything here so I really want to
think that the more subscribers we get
the more of a difference that we can
make because one thing that has become
so important to me and I hope you guys
realize it is the charity that we can do
I mean we've gained about thirty five
thousand subscribers since we did our
last charity livestream or we raised
eight thousand dollars in seven hours
and the next charity livestream is gonna
be next Saturday which I believe is the
ninth of March if I'm not mistaken where
our goal will be $10,000 and we'll raise
that as quick as we can and I will I
will gladly donate a chunk I've been
lucky enough to be able to do this and
I'm actually making us a relatively
decent income I can't explain how much
but it's changed my life with doing this
so I have to be willing to give back if
I'm gonna get stuff from this I have to
be willing to give back so I'm gonna be
donating quite a bit and I hope you guys
can help out and donate as well I don't
know the exact charity that we're
raising for but I will announce it as we
get closer to next weekend but all right
I've kind of hinted that I've kind of
been rambling on on different stuff that
doesn't matter um but I have a new goal
for this channel and it is March 1st
2013 so on March 1st 2014 exactly one
year from now I want this channel to hit
1 million subscribers and that may seem
like an astronomically huge number there
are not that many YouTube channels that
have a million-plus subscribers it's
like just a handful of them that
actually produce content like that but I
I really think that we
chance because a long time ago I said
that I wanted a hundred thousand in a
year and people thought I was crazy and
I said I thought I was crazy too because
I never thought that we'd get there that
because I thought we would get down to
the line you know it'd be in June and
we've like just cushion in the end of
June we really raised it over a hundred
thousand if we ever made it but we made
it about five months early four months
five months four months early so you
guys have really really pulled through
for me and and if we're gonna hit this
goal I need to make sure that I'm
dedicated to helping out people as I go
along every single month every month not
just you know every once in a while
every month we're gonna do another
charity livestream then we're gonna
raise the goal each time and we're gonna
push higher and higher until we can
actually see what we can do and we've if
we start hitting these goals earlier we
got to push them even farther when I'm
doing it because I got to dedicate
myself to do this because I only want to
do this for the right reasons now just
think of the difference that we could do
with this number of people and just
think of the difference we can do with a
million people in here it's astronomical
the good that we can do so please join
me in trying to reach this goal I can't
do it without your help and actually one
of the best ways that channels grow is
simply by word of mouth you know you
only need to tell someone about the
channel to get it to really grow so long
as there's a lot of people talking about
it that's what really drives grouse so I
can't do this without you and I need
your help in order to grow so please if
you haven't already please take some
time out of your day and pick one of my
videos that you think represents the
channel the best it might be the new
segment it might be a compilation it
might be happy wheels I don't know
whatever you think represents the
channel the best and please share it on
Facebook and Twitter or share wherever
or just get a friend to sit down and
watch one of my videos if you can do
this like if everybody watching this
video just shares one video it would go
an astronomically huge way to helping
out
so I want I want you guys to believe
that I'm not in this just to get famous
or anything like this this goal isn't
just me saying I want the biggest
channel on YouTube which I don't I don't
I don't want that I want the biggest
channel that can be able to help people
you know I want to do the most good and
the only way that can be done is with
more people so I don't want you guys to
think I'm ever gonna lose sight of why I
started this and that's why I push
myself to improve every day and I push
myself to come out with better content
every day I want to improve and I want
to help out and we're actually doing
we're doing it faster and better than I
ever thought possible
so thank you guys really truly from the
bottom of my heart thank you I haven't
rambled like this in a V log for a long
time and I I don't know you guys like
just watching me talk for non stop for
about eight minutes now and I could I
could talk for 15 minutes in an hour
about random crap if you watch my
livestream you know I can just ramble on
forever but this what we're building
here means so much to me it's it's the
most important thing that I've ever done
in my life and it's the thing that I've
care about more than anything I've ever
done in my life and it's just incredibly
important that we succeed in not just
helping out ourselves but delivering the
message that gaming and this can be used
to help out I want to be an inspiration
for other channels to look at themselves
and go there's other big channels that
have never done a charity drive and
that's not a character flaw they just
haven't thought of it I mean how many
people out there could make a difference
if we really start this like revolution
of understanding but good can come out
of this because gaming is cast in a bad
light right now with the school shooting
and other stuff like that and gun
control and people blaming violence on
video games we need to put the message
out there that we can build a community
of good we bring people together from
all over the world
towards a common goal and we can do this
we're better than just mindless gamers
even though we love to frag and blow
stuff up I've been shooting aliens since
I was a kid but together we can actually
build something better and do something
better anyway I've rambled on for far
too long I got my message across our new
goal is win 1 year 1 million subscribers
and the only way that that can be done
is with your help
so please spread the word about the
channel let them know that we're not
just a channel here to laugh at gaming
or me screaming like a little girl let
them know that we're building something
better here and this is a community
worth having so thank you all so much
for watching thank you for what you've
done and thank you for changing my life
and thank you for changing the lives of
everyone that we're going to help in the
future so thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye